glenn greenwald is an independent
journalist his work is on substack he
joins us tonight i should say to our
audience we have not talked about this i
have no idea what your views are on this
i was talking to my producers two hours
ago
well just get glenn greenwald he's smart
maybe he'll know what the hell is going
on because i don't but something is what
do you think is happening
well first of all on the question of
biden's capabilities i think it's worth
recalling that throughout 2019 leading
democrats were the ones on that station
on msnbc
in the press who are constantly warning
that biden's cognitive decline was
obvious because they were worried he
would get the nomination and not be able
to withstand the rigors of the election
and he was lucky that the pandemic
happened and he was able to hide in his
basement so that has been a narrative
that came from the democratic party and
obviously it's worsened over the last
two years but i actually
think that one of the things that's
going on here is obviously the corporate
wing of the media the liberal corporate
wing is liberal they're attached to the
democratic party but with one exception
which is they really do believe
constantly in militarism and war their
closest relationships in the media are
with the cia are with the pentagon are
with the national security state they
constantly cheer for war they constantly
want more war and i think that they
don't care about things like crises at
the border or inflation or joblessness
none of which affects them i do think
though that they're deeply offended when
they see america greatness as they
perceive it
falling and failing and these kinds of
images are ones americans are not
accustomed to seeing losing to what is
essentially a primitive fighting force
in the most humiliating manner possible
so i think that it offends their
ideology which believes in militarism
which constantly cheers for war and i
think they're being told by a lot of
their sources in the military in the cia
who they revered the most and who did
not want withdrawal remember tucker when
trump tried to withdraw from afghanistan
the cia invented a lie that russians had
placed bounties on the heads of american
soldiers and leaked it to the new york
times to prevent trump from leaving a
lot of official washington doesn't want
this withdrawal and i they didn't want
it with trump they didn't want it with
biden and i think a lot of the anger is
coming from that
so i was
fervently in favor of withdrawing i'm
grateful that we did withdraw i'm just
defended by the incompetence and the
humiliation that accompanied it what
you're saying is that we imagined
cnn was controlled by the dnc in fact
it's controlled by the cia
exactly and i mean they're certainly the
the two are kind of the same usually
right i mean over the past five years
there's been a merger between the
democratic party and the cia if you look
at polling democrats
democratic voters revere the cia revere
the fbi it's republicans who are
skeptical of of the deep state as a
result of the trump years but i do think
that's part of it but i also think and
this is key is that the the biden plan
to withdraw from afghanistan was founded
and based in a lie from the beginning
which is he kept saying that the afghan
national security forces were strong
enough to withstand the taliban attack
and would hold them off and that it
would be almost impossible for the
taliban to take over the whole country
had he been truthful
with the the american people that once
we went through the taliban would take
over i think the reaction would have
been a lot different i think they
believed him and they feel betrayed as
well by what they told him
i completely agree with that
you know he said the other day in an
interview with abc says it's ugly when
you leave and i think most including me
i would buy that completely it was the
lying that was so infuriating it's
interesting though i mean i've never and
you've covered politics at least as long
as i have i've never seen
like a cabinet secretary or a spokesman
contradict the president on something
meaningful like this repeatedly what is
that
you know i mean look a lot of this is
speculative right we're not we don't
have access to biden's medical records
we're not for sure to examine him we're
not competent medical or psychological
professionals but yes
if you look at joe biden i don't believe
anyone who says that they don't see
clear signs of cognitive decline i see
the discomfort in the faces of kamala
harris and secretary blinken when
they're standing behind him everything
that he says seems very fragile it's
almost like you can see the levers of
his brain kind of slowing down and not
really working well and so half the time
that he says stuff it's left to the rest
of the administration to go and clean it
up i find it uncomfortable to watch the
president of the united states speak and
of course his own aides feel the same
way
yeah i disagree with him of course
but i feel sorry for him every time i
see him so i'm just being honest i feel
sorry for him every single time because
it's just it's awful to watch it's
incredible i appreciate you
that's how it feels to me and his family
knew that's true that's not speculation
that's true i don't know why this was
allowed to happen glenn greenwald thank
you very much
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else